when we were introducing the idea of
volume 10 minutes ago okay and in all
the questions that you've just been
doing in number three we took an area
like this and then we rotated it around
the x-axis like this so you should
picture the potter's wheel spinning in
this direction and then it creates
something down here right because you
get the other side of it as it were but
you don't just have to form a solid of
revolution around the x-axis there's
this whole other axis out there crying
for attention and you can form volumes
on that just as easily so have a look at
this area that I've got you notice it is
not bounded to the x-axis it is bounded
to the y-axis and so it is just as easy
instead of rotating in this horizontal
direction I can rotate in this vertical
direction any questions that you have
where there's at the HSC level anywhere
where there's a volume of solid
revolution involved you'll see the
direction there and that will tell you
which axis you are spinning around have
a think apply your potter's wheel to
this shape in your mind what kind of
object will you get now interestingly
you know how we were looking at the bowl
before that the guy was doing right
you're kind of getting a reverse Bowl
here right because when you do the
rotation you get this kind of shape and
it's sort of spawning spinning around
all in here so you could see it
picturing you're sitting inside a bowl
okay so how do we work out the volume of
this inside a bowl well we have a volume
formula right volume equals but there
are some issues with this volume formula
the way it currently is what are we
adding up you're summing a whole bunch
of things what were they again they were
they were cylinders right but the
cylinders here look ever so slightly
different to the cylinders you've got in
your current diagrams if I were to slice
this I'm gonna get soon as it looks
something like this and you're gonna say
that looks just like the cylinder you
drew before and it does but with the key
difference namely the direction see how
we've chosen a different axis
to spin around I'm not spinning this way
anymore so this cylinder is facing a
different direction and that makes a big
difference for example look at the
height of the cylinder
look at the height see where it is that
doesn't look like a DX to me at all
that's not DX because going the wrong
way that should be a d Y in the same way
have a look at where the radius is the
radius is here that doesn't look like a
Y to me that looks like an X because
it's horizontal okay so as a consequence
my volume formula needs a bit of
twisting around part of the poem to
actually make it work for this
particular volume okay it's still a
cylinder so it's still gonna start with
a PI
it still has a radius but the radius is
different so it's going to be x squared
right there's my radius squared and then
my height of my cylinder is different to
its D Y now you'll notice hopefully
there's a glaring omission from my
integral right what's missing boundaries
are missing okay now normally you would
say look the boundaries are right there
just write them in but hold on not so
quick what are you integrating with
respect to
you are entering with respect to Y so
therefore what you should be putting in
the boundaries should be boundaries with
respect to Y right so they're not 0 and
3 that's sticky if this is 3 and that
means I'm going to here what should this
value up here be it should be 9 okay so
therefore my integral boundaries are not
to 9 in this case anyway okay when you
see this written in textbooks they'll
often say instead of a 2b they'll say
like a CD or something like that just to
remind you hey hey hey it's not the
boundaries you're used to dealing with
okay so this is why as I've been coming
around to lots of you I've been just
gently reminding you please write this
thing right it's not just there for sure
it means something significant and it
tells you to do something different
depending on what that is okay let's
just quickly work this out not to 9pi
now have a look x squared what is x
squared in this case in terms of Y
because I'm about to integrate with
respect to Y it
just why that's convenient okay so why
do you I and now at this point here this
is no longer a volume question it's just
an integral if I wiped off everything
else on the board except this line you
could still do it
I've gonna have what's my primitive y
squared on to and then off you go okay
you know how to do the rest right does
that make sense so you can find out what
that answer is
okay now with that last moment of time I
cannot get away from this first lesson
on volumes of solids of revolution
without solving a mystery for you that
you've been sitting on for four years
namely what's that shape it's a circle
but right now it's not a second anymore
tada it's a sphere now you guys know the
volume of a sphere formula you learn two
years ago what is the volume of a sphere
4 over 3 PI R cubed because it is a
volume 3 dimensions okay now if you were
like me this formula drove you crazy
right and drives you crazy right now cuz
you're like where does it even come from
okay well thankfully for us we now have
tools to help us work out why this is
what it is because if you're a pretty
good very skilled Potter you could make
a solid of revolution that was exactly
this shape you're gonna have to help me
though you need some functions you need
some notation right so what objects
should I rotate in order to create this
sphere it's not a rhetorical question
a semicircle would do it wouldn't it see
that guy there right apply your potter's
wheel to that thing if you spin it
around sure enough that should give you
the sphere yes ok what's the equation of
a semicircle remember this is not just
any same sorry this is not a particular
semicircle I want every semicircle ever
right it's centered on the origin but
what's its equation going to be I'll
give you a clue it starts with that hmm
now if I were the unit circle if it were
the unit circle this would be 1 minus x
squared
wouldn't it
if it were a circle would say radius 5
this would be 25 minus x squared but I
don't just want the unit circle or the
five circle I want any circle so
therefore instead of 1 or 25 I'll write
R squared okay where am i integrating
from what are my boundaries
what's this edge this left edge over
here this is negative R over here and
then you go all the way over to our yeah
okay the scene is set volume equals
ready integral from negative R to R what
are the things we're adding up careful
we're adding up cylinders right so I'm
gonna go PI what axis am i rotating
around in this case anyway X it's worth
say I could have done it the other way
it's the sphere but let's just stick
with that so this is the formula for
rotating around the x-axis right what is
y squared this is that right mm-hmm
that's convenient okay now before I
leave off this I could just integrate
this straight away but I'm gonna do
something a little bit cheap to make it
easier for me this semicircle is a
function with a particular kind of
symmetry what kind of symmetry is it as
a function come on there are two kinds
of symmetry what are they they're odd
and even which one is this one it's even
which means this area over here which
was very rotated and this area over here
which is also being rotated they are
exactly the same so I can do this I
don't need to do both sides I can just
do say one side and then double it cuz
they're the same aren't they how's your
brain going doing all right okay we're
ready to actually integrate I've got my
two at the front in here I've got a PI
now R squared it's just the number it
might be 1 or 25 or 256 but it's just a
number so when I integrate it what does
it become just grabs an X yeah what
about this guy
alarm bells should be going off right
about now because have a look at that
formula that I'm supposed to get to you
see it do you see it are you getting
suspicious all right that's the end of
the primitive I know what my boundaries
are let's evaluate them to at the front
the PI is also out the front what am I
going to get in here I was going to go
in here that's an R cubed I was going to
go in here too isn't it
yeah what about the lower boundary what
happens sort of put the lower boundary
is it every everything's just gone yeah
is that okay - pi what's left inside
look at it carefully r cubed pretty sure
that one take away 1/3 is 2/3 right yeah
yeah I'm done